en 1979 Sadam hussein se convierte en
presidente de Irak inicia una década de
buenas relaciones con Estados Unidos un
eje árabe moderado que acaba en la
siguiente década en 1990 empieza la
guerra del Golfo irá a quien va de
Kuwait y Estados Unidos responde y
expulsa a las tropas iraquíes la guerra
termina un año después Sadam hussein
incrementa La retórica religiosa Aunque
siempre estuvo en contra del islamismo
político y se produce una escalada que
termina siendo definitiva en 2001 caen
las Torres Gemelas en Nueva York y el
mundo cambia para siempre el presidente
George Bush declara la guerra contra el
terror y empieza a hablar de eje del mal
Corea del Norte Irán Y por supuesto Irak
Estados Unidos denuncia que hay armas de
destrucción masiva en Irak y supuestos
vínculos de Sadam hussein con al qaeda
sin apoyo internacional pero con la
alianza de España y Reino Unido bus da
un última tuma Ada m husein desde las
Islas azores portuguesas sin respuesta
del presidente iraquí el 20 de marzo
empieza la guerra con imágenes que ya
son parte de la historia
Seguiremos en nuestra tarea hasta que
hayamos alcanzado Nuestro objetivo que
es liberar a Irak de las armas de
destrucción masiva y liberar al pueblo
iraquí para que pueda vivir en una
sociedad esperanzada y democrática en
paz en su vecindad en menos de dos meses
Estados Unidos impone Un gobierno
dirigido por la coalición internacional
y se dan hussein cae después de 24 años
este escapa hasta ser encontrado a
finales de año después de tres años de
juicios por crímenes de lesa humanidad
es ahorcado el 30 de diciembre de 2006
pese a todos estos antecedentes nunca se
encuentran las armas de destrucción
masiva Y aunque se celebran elecciones
en 2005 irrumpen grupos Insurgentes
yihadistas por lo que las tropas de
Estados Unidos se mantienen hasta 2011
rodeadas de escándalos de corrupción y
torturas y sin llegar a lograr la
ansiada estabilidad
al contrario en 2014 estado islámico
llega a controlar un tercio de Irak el
grupo yihadista no es Derrotado hasta
2017 hoy 20 años después de la guerra y
más de 200.000 muertos los iraquíes
siguen luchando contra la pobreza la
crisis económica sistémica y la
violencia consecuencias de una invasión
justificada en hechos nunca demostrados
cuyos Ecos resuenan en la última de las
invasiones la de Rusia a Ucrania